it seems to me that there is some really
really bad stuff going on in the world
that nobody is talking about so Isis
which is the Islamic state in Syria
they're also known as ISIL which is the
Islamic state in Lille event now they're
just being called is is la McStay t'
they have been going on a rampage
basically through Iraq Iraq really is no
longer a country in any way that we
think countries operate Syria of course
is in the worst civil war going on in
the world right now in about 170,000
people have been killed so we're going
to show you an extremely extremely
graphic video so there's your warning
this is horrible what we're about to
show you but I'm bringing this up
because nobody's talking about this and
and I'm shocked and I really don't
understand why so again warning this is
extremely graphic
la ilaha illa-llah him as agenda under
water maja thermal except the Qualicum
you know the dollar pleasure me husband
Allah who any problem in daily one also
under her alberto cut several class
because the middle woman never idle I'm
in holiness what we're watching whenever
either live University of our Italian
Valley oh boy lucky I'm Sarah laughs
hold on over the whole bow are hatin I
did Allah as Odelia enthusiam one to
unlock appeal jihad al McHale there's a
lot as olden a new tenement had an
assault em keep it one if you don't
listen to semi so what you're seeing
there the beheadings are of Syrian
soldiers loyal to Bashar al-assad done
by Isis now of course it's hard to tell
who the good guys are at hard to tell
who the bad guys are which is part of
the problem and I suspect that's partly
why the media isn't talking about this
because we like really obvious things or
seemingly obvious things the uk-based
Syrian Observatory for Human Rights says
at least 85 government soldiers loyal to
Assad died there right now as we tape
this there is an ethnic group in Iraq
called the ZD they are trapped about
50,000 of them are trapped in the
mountains of Iraq surrounded on all
sides by Isis they are literally
starving to death
nobody's talking about it and nobody's
doing anything I don't know what we
should do but it seems like we should at
least be talking about it so let's talk
about that why is nobody talking about
this I get what's going on in in Israel
and Gaza terrible I get but why are we
seemingly unable to discuss two things
because we're so busy talking about the
Ebola Ebola virus yeah we're not talking
about this I honestly don't know why
people aren't talking about this I mean
at this point in time they now run one
third of Iraq that is a large percentage
of the country and they're now going
into Lebanon and Turkey and they're you
know this is yesterday they went into
Lebanon yesterday this is a crack this
is a crisis and nobody's talking about
and I don't I honestly I don't know why
yeah is this kind of the perfect what
this seems to me is that this is the
perfect storm of George W Bush [ __ ] up
everything
by creating a war in Iraq that we
shouldn't have had yes and then sort of
one online yeah and then Obama was sort
of the perfect president of
disengagement he's that's what he said
from beat one and the best job of that
well even though I need perfect in if
you wanted a perfect storm of sort of
terrible things that I don't think it
was his intent but when he gave that big
speech in Cairo he sort of said we're
gonna pull back and let you guys do
stuff and that's and that's fine but
it's sort of the perfect storm of two
presidents doing completely different
things in a row to allow all this to
happen well I think I think I mean even
more than that there's an issue trying
to force a governmental structure on a
people who aren't interested or willing
to receive it fundamentally that's a
problem but but beyond that I think
going back to your original question why
is nobody paying attention to this my
cynical answer would be that neither of
these groups are our allies
yeah and because neither of their these
groups are allies we have no political
reason to to talk about this human
rights crisis and that's detrimental to
I think our understanding I mean I am
embarrassed to say that I'm sitting here
and I know very little about the
geopolitical conflicts that are
happening in these areas yeah and that's
mostly because I haven't done my due
diligence um but it's not yeah it's not
there you have to really dig for this
and when you talk about we know what's
going on in Israel with with the West
Bank with Gaza we know that because
Israel is a huge political ally of the
American government and you're not gonna
see any kind of political figures in
America speaking up for Gaza ins for
Palestinians you're not and and I mean
what you believe about that way you
don't believe about that it's a very
tricky situation it's pretty it's pretty
obvious where the allegiance of America
lies in that scenario in this scenario
what is it gonna be with Bashar is it
gonna be you know I mean like right like
we sort of think it should be with the
government in Iraq that we built but we
don't seem to be doing much for them and
and also I think I think when something
becomes so incredibly destabilized how
much is kind of putting all of your
stock into a government that's the
losing control going to end up kind of
cashing out in the long run and that's
really unfortunately the way that the
American government looks at these
situations their strategic individual
people are head counts you know and no
[ __ ] horrible pun intended here but I
think more more than the political and
more than the the war that's happening
there what nobody's talking about is the
fact that like people are dying in a
very kind of savage savage draconian way
so is that is that then part of it that
this is so savage that partly you know
idiot everyone keep saying the images
out of guys are horrible which they are
but there's a definitive narrative it's
a bomb that drops on a war that we
recognize yes and it's that's how we've
seen war yeah you know this is this is
not that this is this is savage this is
like it it's like some medieval yeah it
is you know [ __ ] evil it's something
you'd see on Game of Thrones you have
seen on Game of Thrones like this is
something we don't understand maybe
maybe that's another reason people
aren't talking about it's like how do
you and they begin to talk about this
where does this mentality come from yeah
you know how does somebody I mean how
does somebody al-qaida has disavowed
this group because of their their
behavior because it's so savage so like
how does someone become the person that
beheads
another human being and puts it on
display for everyone to see I just
that's and why I mean why why aren't we
doing anything I mean it's a massacre
yeah you know Rwanda happened other
things have happened where there's been
massacres and yes we waited and waited
and waited or we did not do anything
about it and maybe that was political
cuz there was no political like there
was no incentive there's no privacy for
us there's no question right now look
there is a lot of oil play obviously
especially especially in Iraq I don't
know what we're supposed to do but this
thing right now with the Yazidi in the
in the mountains they're literally dying
of starving children yeah ethnic group
that's existed in Iraq for thousands of
years yes um I guess we could have some
airstrikes on the ISIS soldiers that are
around the mountains you know ii mean
i'm not calling for more military
intervention but like is there something
we could do that wouldn't risk any
american lives yeah probably
or just i mean simple humanitarian aid
and i know that there's gonna be
pushback that it's really hard to
deliver humanitarian
when there's military intervention on
the other side right what you try to do
we've seen this happen all the time or
we've seen this happen historically in
Africa where we tried to deliver
humanitarian aid warlords will pick up
the the meal packages whatever we're
delivering keep them from the people the
warlords are getting richer it's it's a
it's complicated as [ __ ] I think removal
Wilson yeah I think this is my this is
my profession elephant
uh there's something to be said about a
group of people that seems like they're
behind the rest of the world and I think
that that's a mentality that's hard for
us to sit with like we should be past
this right like we're more modern than
this and when you see you arrested over
hold it is more modernist exactly the
rest of the world is more modern this
group is so behind is so ass-backward
that it's like you were saying there's
such a disconnect how do you even begin
to intervene because the arguments that
you make the diplomacy that you try to
do doesn't translate and that becomes a
huge sticking point I think that's where
the real difficulty lies so final
thought I mean is there anything that we
should be doing do you think I mean I
mean we're just letting it go to hell in
a handbag is there anything I I don't
know I mean I for me I feel like yeah
there's there's fifty thousand people
that are up on a hill now running away
from these people and I feel like and
any point in time I know it's
complicated but I feel like uh we're the
united states we can do anything we want
to do and you know these people are just
gonna die if somebody doesn't help them
and we've gone into their countries and
we've you know created havoc and we
haven't stabilized anything as as we can
see and then we just left okay well now
we're just gonna leave and we're gonna
leave you to deal with pick up the
pieces of yes that's what are you
problems that also goes to what I meant
about the Obama the Bush Obama usually
respond without money it up so terribly
so even right do we have a
responsibility even if even if we don't
want to yeah and we believe in the idea
of disengaging if we're the ones that
screwed it up do we at least owe fifty
thousand people on a metropolis for
looking mr reason just about you know
we help the people do stunts make
something I don't know I don't go into
someone's house and make a mess and then
be like all right I'm gonna go home now
and leave your kitchen in disarray like
I hope someone clean up their kitchen
and then I leave but then again I you
know I was raised with manners
unlike Isis
[Music]